now hans how are you feeling about your  play today  i'm just happy i didn't lose this game  yeah because i really had to go to the  bathroom so badly and i was sitting  there like how long should i wait and i  was like no no i can i can make it  through the game  and then and then i was like no if i if  i have to play it with  in serious pain it's just going to go  badly  so it worked out but  i'm just happy to like not  make it to four games it's just america  already  but uh i feel good and uh okay uh  like this i feel like  despite the scorpion even i've been in  control every single like the first game  i should have won it was so ridiculous  like uh  so okay i feel like i'm asserting  dominance and i don't feel like  my um morale is completely crushed  so uh that's at least progress good luck  we look forward to